but stay on the line with us for the
moment because we're reaching the top of
the hour it is 1400 GMT and I would just
want to reset for people who may be
joining us as we speak just a few
moments ago a very short while ago we
learned that a blast had occurred you're
seeing pictures of what appeared to be
that blast the blast had occurred in
central Istanbul we were talking about
the taxim area specifically istic Laos
streets and as our correspondent synonym
has just been explaining to us this is
uh very busy part of Istanbul at what
would have been and what was a very busy
time of the day in taxim on istecloud
streets and I'm also giving us the
context that Istanbul which is used to
these kinds of attacks hadn't seen
anything like this for a few years this
is going to bring back some very hard
memories very tough memories for
residents of Istanbul um synonym the
question I've been wanting to ask you
in the recent past has there been
anything anything at all that would
suggest that the Threat Level had been
raised in Istanbul or anywhere else in
turkey that maybe an attack was underway
and I I want to also couch this by
saying we don't know what has occurred
yet we don't know who is behind this we
don't even know if we can really call
this an attack at this stage or how the
explosion occurred why it occurred we
don't know any of this at this stage
it's very important to uh to make that
clear nonetheless there was uh a big
blast in the center of Istanbul with the
Reuters press agency reporting that at
least 11 people are injured sending back
to that question was there any
indication that the Threat Level had
gone up
well as I said this was very surprising
for all three parties the government
which includes the security uh officers
uh the residents of Istanbul and also
turkey and the tourists because uh
sometimes they say the these kinds of
incidents happen at the time when you
feel so confident because for the last
couple of days especially the government
officials including the president have
been explaining to the Turkish people
that you know
we we got rid of these kinds of attacks
everything is safe we provided safety
security we cleared out from uh from
terrorist attacks we wiped the pkk out
of uh two kids borders turkey has a
security policy of uh ending these kinds
of uh attacks before it reaches inside
a turkey's border so this is what they
have been proud of but as you said there
are strong suspicions that this is a
suicide bomb but we don't have any
official statement yet and the official
statements are binding for us but when
you look at the pictures
um we see that this is a similar scene
of what happened a couple of years ago
on Istanbul Street many many people
would remember a tourist group was also
uh involved actually was affected by
such an incident uh there were Israeli
tourists in that group and there was a
suicide bomber so it happened so
suddenly but uh in terms of any uh
indication that trucia or Istanbul could
be prone to such an attack these days or
recently we we haven't heard anything we
haven't heard any reports we didn't hear
any emergency warnings from the security
officials of turkey so this is stunning
because uh especially Istanbul
especially after the coup attempt in
2016 has been very strict in terms of
security
at night during traffic and the number
of the security the police Personnel was
increased inside the city after 2016
because also the city the the official
population of the city shows more than
16 million on paper uh with the 2020
figures but with the uh Syrian uh
refugees with the uh domestic uh uh
with more people moving into Istanbul
the City's population uh probably hit
around 20 million this is what the
experts say they calculate uh they they
presume true care as Istanbul as a city
of 20 million so when you have such a
crowd when you have so many social
diverse ethnic and social groups and so
many tourists coming over the
Istanbul can again be targeted but as I
said we had no indications at these as
the citizens no one had any indication
because the area has been safe people
are going out freely at night during the
day and in Turkey
the bars the clubs you know the The
Nightlife doesn't end around 10 pm
so Istanbul has a very active night life
as well and it's the class Street where
this explosion happened is such an area
it's always busy it's always life and
there is all that's why there is always
police around the area civilian or in
uniforms doesn't matter so uh that's why
uh I I cannot say there was a Threat
Level increasing and that Istanbul could
be targeted by any kind of such attack
sure synonym
um I am seeing on the Associated Press
that the Istanbul Governor has tweeted
about this and he says that there are
fatalities in this explosion that is
something that we did not have a handle
on until right now this is a rapidly
developing situation but it does appear
according to the Istanbul Governor cited
by the Associated Press that there are
now fatalities uh to be deplored in this
explosion